i could do one more
i'll do one more oh my gosh
this is madness am i white
wait oh these things can't move though
oh that's so funny
oh i'm black wait what so i can't really
do anything with these things
until much later
what is this
a phone has a decently high rating too
i'm basically up
about 48 points but the extra 48
it's all paralyzed and i'm low on space
wow this is actually fascinating
this is really fascinating
because i might just be in trouble
i feel like like if we ask the even the
engine the engine will say black's
winning but
it's really not so simple
i mean the plan is just trade
it's gonna be really hard though to
force whites
like the only way to actually make use
of this stuff
is to force white to capture a piece
so i think what this has done it's just
made the board smaller
so the chessboard is now a rectangle
and at first i thought this was going to
be a challenge because i lack space but
white also lacks space
yeah the chessboard is now just a
rectangle
or just a square that's been widened
or squished so let's play let's create
some tension
yeah like this whole part of the board
is irrelevant white can never take
anything because then it's just probably
an auto loss
um so i don't think it benefits me in
any way
this is fascinating i
i don't think the engine would
understand this i think sockfish would
would give like
a huge number for black even though it's
probably close to equal
question is do i imbalance
yeah it's it's it's also like a crowded
elevator
i think i do want to take here because
e7 is a valuable square
yeah like
this is a very crowded elevator
now the question is are knights are
probably better than bishops
because everything's more compact like
you're not using the whole board
so the long-range power of a bishop is
less relevant
so i think that was a good trade play g6
try and trap the queen oh this bishop
this is not normal for the bishop to be
staring at this pawn
oh that was a blunder by me too
okay white miss queen e2 i think
if i'm not mistaken let's play c6 so
undermining this bishop
oh i have to be careful of this move too
the rooks are
man i didn't realize the power of the
bishops
i think f6 was only move idea king of
seven
if ever queen here i can always block
g5 i have ways to defend
now this is really fascinating
i'm curious how my opponent like
discovered this or
saw it somewhere like who thinks of this
stuff
okay so i think i want to preserve my
knight
i mean b3 might be coming b3 is very
double edged though
because it does attack the pinned upon
but it also
exposes the rook potentially there's
always a tactic
like there's all these weird checks like
queen b6 check is usually not a thing
and um and
uh when the board is larger
i'm wondering if i can play this move
now
so this is very multi-purpose
obstructing this bishop
and opening the diagonal now queen e7
castling is still probably legal oh
white can't castle because the king's on
e3
that's nice to to realize
so maybe that's my like that's one one
advantage i have
i wonder if my opponent enabled castling
for me
okay let's see what happens here
so after king d2 i think i think the
game plan is
oh bishop okay this
let's say i think the game plan is this
but this pawn is kind of pinned to the
rook
so it's a question do i want to sack the
rook from nice pawns
not so clear
i could just take the bishop though win
a piece
okay so i'm up a piece
i'm trying to oh i didn't realizing
i can never promote
so i can never castle but i can never
promote
i'm i'm discovering so many like new
layers
to this position like once i just got a
pawn here it's just dead
i can never oh so being up a piece is
not
not going to be a decisive advantage
whoa it's elshon with a giant raid
thanks all sean
if you're just joining this is actually
really confusing
um i've been kind of learning along the
way in this position
like i'm up a piece but i don't know if
it's winnable i'm actually up 50
50 points in terms of material
thinking of seven king f7 over defends
the pawn so
i'm trying to mobilize a knight like
this is a nice potential square for the
knight
kind of outpost and then maybe prepare
like once 97 is played it will prepare
prepare f5 as well
oh yeah shout out to al shawn things
might see it hope you had a good stream
i really appreciate it yeah let's go for
this yeah it's just a matter of
developing
a bit cramped but i do have squares for
the pieces
hmm i mean
i could very well play i want to say f3
but it's f5
at the right moment
so it's a question if i play f5 first
which makes some sense i'm calculating
here and then f5
but then i i leave the tension
i think i'll yeah keep things tense
lexiconius gifting us up to al-shaan
thanks so much lexiconius i appreciate
that
yeah after this game i'll do some some
analysis like cyclists
stock stock fish will be i think
not at all useful
which is actually kind of fascinating
yeah so because we both have dark
squared bishops it's usually
uh to both of our benefits to have pawns
on light squares so white's doing a
better job of that on the king side
um but i am threatening some discoveries
and that move kind of makes me happier
so take with this pawn keep the pawn duo
maybe prepare this
oh normally i would be
i don't advise like giving computer
evaluation
but uh yeah that was kind of expected
and yeah this doesn't doesn't reflect
the true nature of the position
you could even replace all of these with
queens i wonder if
that would create like minus 120.
wait i don't want to get too long time
this move and leave the knights
defending the pawn
yeah like i want to take and do things
but
oh this is actually slightly annoying
probably this move and then
it's a concept of over defending i over
defend c6 to
uh to mobilize this knight
oh but i can taken this knight's hanging
there we go
i think two p like being up two pieces
is enough to win
and there's increment two so about
enough time
if we i'm just imagining like running
the computer graph on this game
it'll just be like a flat line like box
always winning
okay let's um
yeah let's develop the knight
so we traded off everything from here
like if both rooks and
wait can i meet with two knights
actually trying to imagine the scenario
where i just have
two nights if probably not
because yeah the fact that the board
gets a little bit smaller doesn't change
much
okay so yeah like these pawns like i can
never promote
unless unless white goes after this pawn
well i can play rook here
and then take and fork my rooks
that would be so nice all i need is like
one
it's like um what you call it
the thing that stops hurricanes not
hurricanes
tidal waves levees
all you need is like one hole for the
levee for the water to just sink in
well okay let's um let's try and
organize some mating that i'm playing
knight d5
like the king is already a bit confined
imagining some eventual night in bishop
mates
it's close
i want to play this move and then this
one doesn't quite work though
there is a potential mate with um that
we're coming to before
interesting
wait a minute
that's tricky okay i want to preserve
i want to preserve my bishop
the structure is kind of annoying though
okay white white has more things to be
annoyed about
like white's almost from zuzwan because
this rook's tied down to the pawn
this rook this pawn can't move the king
can barely move
i guess the king could move here
yeah the the goal is to put white in
zugzwang
how i gotta move
i'm controlling all these squares
if i could play this move i i can just
start eating the pawns
and brook g3 shouldn't change much
let's go for this and then yeah it's me
okay that was that was really
interesting
like that's that's very like kind of
mind-boggling
um and yeah white so
i guess i'm still trying to comprehend
this but white probably has an advantage
initially i thought it was just going to
be kind of equal on a smaller board
but white can promote in black camp
promote
what stock fish stockfish
what a dumb machine yeah if we um
does it have computer analysis
it's just going to be a flat line like
box always winning
but i wonder like if
if we play the game where white
eventually wins like at what point would
it switch its mind
yeah like the stockfish will give no
insight to this position
i'll just say every move is winning
pretty much
which is hilarious
there's a moment here i was thinking
about taking but after it takes
takes
i actually wasn't sure in a position
like this
like let's imagine the the final works
get traded
um like here here here
i'm not sure if this is winnable
oh though it probably is winnable with
presence of pawns because i can i can
use the knights to drive the king to the
side and then meet yeah this would be my
oh but the
thing is queening oh this is yeah never
mind
i have to assuming i catch this pawn
then it should be winnable
but this is this might even be winning
for white at this point
i don't know
anyway uh i think i'm gonna put this
that on on youtube
um it's like a mind-boggling position
that stockfish has no clue about
so people on youtube hope you enjoyed
that if you have insights
let me know leave a comment like
subscribe
i'll see you in the future